c'est le premier navire de la saison le
cas reviennent princess battant pavillon
bermudien à son bord 1200 membres
d'équipage pour 3000 passagers selon les
statistiques habituelles 80% environ
d'entre eux descendront à terre prêts
pour l'aventuré
la bouffe est bonne les gens sont
chaleureux
on peut parler notre turn et puis vous
trouvez toujours à visiter quelque chose
de nouveau
l'eau se retire à faire question se tira
on va prendre un taxi alors c'est lui
qui va nous amener où bon lui ça n'est
pas encore venu ici mais nous
connaissons déjà toutes les îles de la
caraïbe et l'on s'est dit vous venez en
martinique
qu'attendez-vous de cette destination je
ne sais pas encore elle est différente
des autres
la culture française ce sera différent
des îles anglaises ou encore des îles
espagnoles
je veux goûter la nourriture
je veux voir le volcan à celui qui est
entré en éruption
il y a deux ou trois choses que je veux
découvrir pour nous pendant la saison
s'annonce moins florissante que la
précédente avec le retour sur les
itinéraires des îles impacté l'an
dernier par irma et maria 210 bateaux
sont programmés contre 345 l'an dernier
un retour à la normale pourrait-on dire
dont l'importance de capter un maximum
de clients pour les activités à terre
ont vendu à bord
je crois savoir qu'il ya une quinzaine
de produits et puis maintenant vous avez
toutes les visites que vous pouvez faire
de manière individuelle en passant par
en apprenant artisans taxis en prenant
la navette par exemple pour se rendre
aux trois ilets
en prenant le tcsp donc les passagers
justement se renseigne et en fonction
des informations qu'ils ont
ils vont organiser leur journée sur la
destination
ça reste encore une saison assez
intéressante puisqu'on on est sur des
niveaux en terme de volume de passagers
qui sont équivalents à ce que ce qu'on
avait en 2016 2017
donc maintenant
il faut assurer des prestations de
qualité une qualité qui se traduit d'une
saison à l'autre par un plus grand
nombre de réservations depuis le bateau
pour cette reprise les chiffres sont
bons 23% des passagers ont déjà bouclé
leurs journées best-seller l'excursion
rome et bananes ou l'observation des
tortues autant de clients bienvenus du
nord au sud de lille